[Musique]
le picard vous incarner le tueur à gages
gérald gallant dans confessions c'est
tout un rôle de composition pour vous
parce que gérald gallant il bégaie il
souffre aussi beaucoup alors comment
faire l'approché ce personnage là qui
étape qui est vraiment complexe et c'est
ce qui serait une composition assez
imposante maison j'avais des heures et
des heures d'interrogatoire de gala et
puis je regardais ça à temps perdu je
regarde être le faisais je le pratiquais
chez moi je me suis mis à bégayer dans
la vie
j'essaie s avec mongolie et bon public
mongai il ya un bon oeil puis je dis bah
ça sonne tout naturel que je les vends à
peu près 7 8 mois j'étais un peu là
dedans j'ai toujours pratiqué dans tout
cela mon chat est toujours oui parce que
quand tu t'arrêtes en lumière rouge les
autres organes comme si c'était foutu
[Musique]
en
2002 vous avez aussi joué les criminels
dans moïse l'histoire de rock thériault
dans le collectionneur ou 6 1 un tueur
en série mais jouer les criminels comme
ça ce cas carrière avait déjà reçu une
question que je lance comme ça dès
maintenant parce que nécessairement ils
ont des cercles rapprochés ces gens
donnent les intérêts
ouais ben écoute c'est la première fois
que je joue quelqu'un vraiment parce que
voyez-vous moïse mais moïse était en
prison
et bizarrement c'est vrai que paris iv
ton d'un film comme celui l'oeil il ya
toujours cette espèce de faty et qui est
dessus mais j'essaie de ne pas trop
penser à ma question était possible que
ces
deux pierres ont marqué votre carrière
pierre bernard au théâtre louis pierre
falardeau aussi qu'est ce que ces deux
hommes là ces deux artistes vous ont
montré du métier qui vous suit encore
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oh mon dieu tellement de choses mais je
dirais peut-être j a trouvé un mot c'est
la sincérité
et chez pier richer pierre les deux et
l'idéalisme aussi le rêve le droit de
rêver le devoir de rêver en fait le
sujet
coupez en fait c'était ma prochaine
question pierre falardeau a quitté il ya
plus de dix ans il me manque je te même
pas mon ami ce qui manque d un côté
artiste qu elle aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
perdre falardeau il était sincère on
voudrait que ça nous manque un peu au
québec non ouais c'est le manque
peut-être un peu partout c'est parce que
c'est ce que la rectitude politique fait
que
rectitude ça dit bon ça dit déjà une
chose puis personne ne peut être contre
la vertu sauf qu'il ya des choses qu'on
a exprimées ne sont pas toujours si
vertueuse que ça puis si tu veux juste
les cacher mais tu veux je te mentir
fact et pas plus avancé
donc des fois il faut pouvoir se laisser
l'uspi dire des choses puis il faut
avoir le droit de se tromper parce que
si tu peux pas te tromper jamais grand
chose et
puis la beauté de l'être humain c'est
dans nos failles
aussi c'est pas juste quand on est
adéquat ou correct c'est parce que moi
les êtres humains j'aime bien c'est leur
faille que je vous avais déjà dit en
entrevue que votre fils henry est la
plus belle aventure de toute votre vie
alors comment je m'en cette aventure là
à changer votre carrière et votre façon
de jouer d'une certaine façon parce
qu'encore une fois vous être très émotif
lorsque vous parlez de votre fils qui
est comédien oui ouais
ben ari ça a changé ma vie parce que
parce qu'un enfant ça change pas d'avis
mais je passe à côté
c'est fait pour se changer ta vie
puis ça a changé ma carrière parce que
j'ai écrit l'audition pour
fait je serais jamais devenu réalisateur
il mettra ses épaules mais
je suis devenu réalisateur à partir d'un
récit j'ai
une audition c'est parti d'une lettre
que j'avais écrit tard à mon goût fait
que ouais c'est un fake henri ben c'est
une révolution comme comme je pense les
enfants doivent toujours et des
révolutions pour les gens qui qui les
font c'est un lâche tente ma chance que
nous traversons un film sur guy lafleur
oui moi je très bien votre fils henry
guy lafleur jeunes et le pic à guy
lafleur plus vieux
je suis loin de la vérité ou web parce
qu'on n'en est pas là du tout j'en ai
vraiment assez de trouver le
on n'est pas au casting première map
deuxièmement
j'ai l'intuition que l'histoire de
glisse temps de repos jusqu'à 7h ou
mondange à moi alors je pense que je
trouve que pour eux je trouve pour pour
notre jeu tout faire un prospère
il ya des limites quand même fait une
offre cependant une dans les réflexions
je suis vraiment l'écriture donc le
picard on peut voir cet été dans
confessions mais aussi dans arsenault et
fils veut vraiment dire parce que aussi
extraordinaire là bas merci beaucoup
merci un film merci
s'aggraver